that night at the dinner table he
brought it out and set it down beside
her plate
Doris stared at it her hand to her mouth
my god what is it she looked up at him
bright-eyed well open it Doris tore the
ribbon and paper from the square package
with her sharp nails her bosom rising
and falling
Larry stood watching her as she lifted
the lid he lit a cigarette and leaned
against the wall a cuckoo clock
Doris cried a real old cuckoo clock like
my mother had she turned the clock over
and over just like my mother had when
Pete was still alive her eyes sparkled
with tears it's made in Germany Larry
said after a moment he added Carl got it
for me wholesale he knows some guy in
the clock business otherwise I wouldn't
have he stopped
Doris made a funny little sound I mean
otherwise I wouldn't have been able to
afford it he scowled
what's the matter with you you've got
your clock haven't you isn't that what
you want
Doris at holding on to the clock her
fingers pressed against the brown wood
well Larry said what's the matter
he watched an amazement as she leaped up
and ran from the room still clutching
the clock he shook his head never
satisfied they're all that way they
never get enough he sat down at the
table and finished his meal
the cuckoo clock was not very large it
was handmade however and there were
countless frets on it little
indentations in ornaments scored in the
soft wood Doris sat on the bed drying
her eyes and winding the clock she set
the hands by her wristwatch presently
she carefully moved the hands to two
minutes of ten she carried the clock
over to the dresser and propped it up
then she sat waiting her hands twisted
together in her lap waiting for the
cuckoo to come out for the hour to
strike as she sat she thought about
Larry and what he had said and what she
had said too for that matter not that
she could be blamed for any of it after
all she couldn't keep listening to him
forever
without defending herself you had to
blow your own trumpet in the world she
touched her handkerchief to her eyes
suddenly why did he have to say that
about getting it wholesale why did he
have to spoil it all if he felt that way
he needn't have got it in the first
place she clenched her fists he was so
mean so damn mean but she was glad of
the little clock sitting there ticking
to itself with its funny grilled edges
in the door inside the door was the
cuckoo waiting to come out was he
listening his head cocked on one side
listening to hear the clock strike so
that he would know when to come out did
he sleep between hours well she would
soon see him she could ask him and she
would show the clock to Bob he would
love it
Bob loved old things even old stamps and
buttons he liked to go with her to the
stores of course it was a little awkward
but Larry had been staying at the office
so much and that helped if only Larry
didn't call up sometimes too there was a
were the clock shuddered and all at once
the door opened the cuckoo came out
sliding swiftly he paused and looked
around solemnly scrutinizing her the
room the furniture it was the first time
he had seen her she realized smiling to
herself in pleasure she stood up coming
toward him shyly go on she said I'm
waiting
the cuckoo opened its bill he word and
chirped quickly rhythmically then after
a moment of contemplation he retired and
the door snapped shut she was delighted
she clapped her hands and spun in a
little circle he was marvelous perfect
and the way he had looked around
studying her sizing her up he liked her
she was certain of it and she of course
loved him at once completely he was just
what she had hoped would come out of the
little door Doris went to the clock she
bent over the little door her lips close
to the wood do you hear me she whispered
I think you're the most wonderful cuckoo
in the world she paused embarrassed I
hope you'll like it here then she went
downstairs again slowly her head high
Larry in the cuckoo clock really never
got along well from the start
Doris said it was because he didn't wind
it right and it didn't like being only
half wound all the time Larry turned the
job of winding over to her the cuckoo
came out every quarter hour and ran the
spring down without remorse and someone
had to be ever after it winding it up
again Doris did her best but she forgot
a good deal of the time then Larry would
throw his newspaper down with an
elaborate weary motion and stand up he
would go into the dining room where the
clock was mounted on the wall over the
fireplace he would take the clock down
and making sure that he had his thumb
over the little door he would wind it up
why do you put your thumb over the door
Doris asked once you're supposed to she
raised an eyebrow are you sure I wonder
if it isn't that you don't want him to
come out while you're standing so close
why not maybe you're afraid of him
Larry laughed he put the clock back on
the wall and gingerly removed his thumb
when Doris wasn't looking he examined
his thumb there was still a trace of the
Knik cut out of the soft part of it
who or what had pecked at him one
Saturday morning when Larry was done at
the office working over some important
special accounts Bob chambers came to
the front porch and rang the bell Doris
was taking a quick shower she dried
herself and slipped into her robe when
she opened the door Bob stepped inside
grinning hi he said looking around it's
alright Larry's at the office fine
Bob gazed at her slim legs below the hem
of the robe how nice you look today she
laughed
be careful maybe I shouldn't let you in
after all they looked at one another
half amused and half frightened
presently Bob said if you want all know
for God's sake she caught hold of his
sleeve just get out of the doorway so I
can close it mrs. peters across the
street you know she closed the door and
I want to show you something she said
you haven't seen it he was interested in
antique or what she took his arm leading
him toward the dining room you'll love
it Bobby
she stopped wide-eyed I hope you will
you must you must love it it means so
much to me he means so much he Bob
frowned who is he
Doris laughed you're jealous come on a
moment later they stood before the clock
looking up at it he'll come out in a few
minutes wait until you see him I know
you two will get along just fine
what does Larry think of him they don't
like each other
sometimes when Larry's here he won't
come out larry gets mad if he doesn't
come out on time he says says what Doris
looked down he always says he's been
robbed even if he did get it wholesale
she brightened but I know he won't come
out because he doesn't like Larry when
I'm here alone he comes out right for me
every 15 minutes even though he really
only has to come out on the hour she
gazed up at the clock he comes out for
me because he wants to we talk I tell
him things of course I'd like to have
him upstairs in my room but it wouldn't
be right there was the sound of
footsteps on the front porch they looked
at each other horrified Larry pushed the
front door open grunting he said his
briefcase down and took off his hat then
he saw Bob for the first time Chambers
I'll be
his eyes narrowed what are you doing
here he came into the dining room
Doris threw her robe about her
helplessly backing away I Bob began that
is we he broke off glancing at Doris
suddenly the clock began to were the
cuckoo came rushing out bursting into
sound
Larry moved toward him shut that din off
he said he raised his fist toward the
clock
the cuckoo snapped into silence and
retreated the door closed that's better
Larry studied Doris and Bob standing
mutely together I came over to look at
the clock Bob said Doris told me that
it's a rare antique in that nuts I
bought it myself
Larry walked up to him get out of here
he turned to Doris you too and take that
damn clock with you he paused rubbing
his chin no leave the clock here it's
mine I bought it and paid for it in the
weeks that followed after Doris left
Larry in the cuckoo clock got along even
worse than before for one thing the
cuckoo stayed inside most of the time
sometimes even at 12 o'clock when he
should have been busiest and if he did
come out at all he usually spoke only
once or twice never the correct number
of times and there was a sullen
uncooperative note in his voice a
jarring sound that made Larry uneasy and
a little angry but he kept the clock
wound because the house was very still
and quiet and it got on his nerves not
to hear someone running around talking
and dropping things and even the
whirring of a clock sounded good to him
but he didn't like the cuckoo at all and
sometimes he spoke to him listen he said
late one night to the closed little door
I know you can hear me I ought to give
you back to the Germans back to the
Black Forest he paced back and forth I
wonder what they're doing now the two of
them that young punk with his books and
his antiques a man shouldn't be
interested in antiques that's where
women he said his jaw isn't that right
the clock said nothing Larry walked up
in front of it isn't that right
he demanded don't you have anything to
say
he looked at the face of the clock it
was almost 11 just a few seconds before
the hour all right I'll wait until 11:00
then I want to hear what you have to say
you've been pretty quiet the last few
weeks since she left he grinned wryly
maybe you don't like it here since she's
gone
he's scowled well I paid for you and
you're coming out whether you like it or
not
you hear me 11 o'clock came far off at
the end of town the great tower clock
boomed sleepily to itself but the little
door remains shut nothing moved the
minute hand passed on and the cuckoo
didn't stir he was someplace inside the
clock beyond the door
silent and remote all right if that's
the way you feel
Larry murmured his lips twisting but it
isn't fair it's your job to come out we
all have to do things we don't like
he went unhappily into the kitchen and
opened the great gleaming refrigerator
as he poured himself a drink he thought
about the clock there was no doubt about
it
the cuckoo should come out Doris or no
Doris he had always liked her from the
very start they had got along well the
two of them probably he liked Bob too
probably he had seen enough of Bob to
get to know him they would be quite
happy together Bob and Doris and the
cuckoo
Larry finished his drink he opened the
drawer at the sink and took out the
hammer he carried it carefully into the
dining room the clock was ticking gently
to itself on the wall look he said
waving the hammer you know what I have
here you know what I'm going to do with
it I'm gonna start on you first
he smiled birds of a feather that's what
you are the three of you the room was
silent are you coming out or do I have
to come in and get you the clock word a
little I hear you in there you've got a
lot of talking to do enough for the last
three weeks as I figure it you owe me
the door opened the cuckoo came out fast
straight at him Larry was looking down
his brow wrinkled and thought he glanced
up and the cuckoo caught him squarely in
the eye down he went
hammer and chair and everything hitting
the floor with a tremendous crash for a
moment that cuckoo paused its small body
poised rigidly then it went back inside
its house
the door snapped tight shut after it the
man lay on the floor stretched out
grotesquely his head bent over to one
side nothing moved or stirred the room
was completely silent except of course
for the ticking of the clock
I see Doris said her face tight Bob put
his arm around her steadying her dr. Bob
said can I ask you something of course
the doctor said is it very easy to break
your neck falling from so low a chair it
wasn't very far to fall I wonder if it
might not have been an accident is there
any chance it might have been suicide
the doctor rubbed his jaw I never heard
of anyone committing suicide that way it
was an accident
I'm positive I don't mean suicide Bob
murmured under his breath looking up at
the clock on the wall I meant something
else but no one heard him
the afternoon Sun dappled the fields
like droplets of honey shining on the
backs of the men as they gathered the
remaining harvest in their blue black
hands far off a brick structure stood
like a paper cut out against the sky its
tall stacks producing a haze that hung
over the landscape the promise of a
storm to come emma pulled her head
inside the carriage sliding her fingers
beneath the rug on her lap I had no idea
industry had come to the state Allen
Belle her fiance scowled out at the
passing scene saying nothing Emma smiled
at him it seems winter is fast on its
way
he'd been sullen since they'd started
this Trek the nearer they came to bounty
Falls the less he seemed to speak at
last her attempts to draw him out were
successful it always arrives before one
is ready he said
Emma's gaze wandered to the window again
two miles of neat rows outside now
mostly stripped of their bounty the
silhouettes of the mountaintops were
just visible on the horizon closing in
like stone gates Emma had seen mountains
before but these seemed more imposing
participants in a conspiracy to oppress
- away her unease she refocused on the
men in the fields is it true what I read
that the freedmen have been given the
vote out of the corner of her eyes she
saw Allen's mouth twist it was true for
certain of them their suffrage was
repealed at the last convention Emma sat
back against the wooden bench slipping
her hands from beneath the rug to tuck a
stray curl under her hat do you think
their suffrage will be reinstated I've
no gift for prognostication Emma
shrugged accustomed to his faint
churlish nests it was the only quality
she disliked about him although she
never would have said so surely progress
will win out in the end
Allen stared hard at a spot just past
her right shoulder don't say so in front
of my father
his tone signified the conversation was
ended
Emma shrugged again and closed her eyes
when she opened them begin a half hour
later the carriage was making its way
down the main road of bounty Falls even
in the impending darkness Emma saw a
neat little store fronts of whitewashed
brick square two story forms bearing a
pleasing sameness in their sensible
arrangement of windows and doors Emma
turned to Allen as the carriage bumped
along the dirt track you didn't do it
justice mr. bell she said coquettish Lee
accusing its charming Allen stony facade
shifted it is I can't imagine why you'd
want to leave it Ellen's features
underwent a curious transformation
displaying first would appear to be a
deep and seething rage that was then
replaced by a foggy expression of loss
and uncertainty I can't remember exactly
why I left his voice was like the wisp
of a remembered nightmare youthful
impetuousness perhaps
em'ly disturbed by Alan's reaction let
the matter rest the carriage shuddered
to a halt before another brick structure
this one larger and more elegant than
the others and set apart from the town
proper fluted columns glowed white in
the dusk framing a glass door upon which
was etched Horace Bell clock maker the
carriage driver helped him into the
ground she stirred on the dirt path and
looked around enchanted
but now bothered by something she just
noticed Alan where is everyone for the
streets were deserted and even the upper
windows of the shops where people
presumably lived for know flickering
lights Alan picked up a heavy trunk with
ease seemingly irritated by the question
they've all turned in early to be ready
for the festival I suspect you'll see
them tomorrow
Emma nodded peering back over her
shoulder her fingers playing at the lace
collar of her dress a Bell jingled in
the silence and Emma looked up to see
that Alan's father Horace Bell had
emerged from the glass door and was
standing on the porch his shadowed form
barely visible he stood there apparently
looking down at them and for a
spellbinding moment Emma had the
impression he was not a man at all but
some force of nature a simulacrum of a
human but a spirit of far older and
darker persuasion a manifestation of the
eternal bound in a shell of skin and
bone then he stepped down from the porch
into the fading light and he was just a
man after all the one that oddly
resembled a sculpture and polished oak
Emma dazed by the force of her bizarre
delusion offered her hand as he
approached lovely to meet you miss
Sullivan his voice was a thick Rumble he
took her hand briefly and squeezed it
I've heard a great deal about your
family Oh Emma couldn't understand why
she was becoming flustered and with a
studied act of will she managed to call
him her pounding heart it's beautiful
here she said mr. bells chest swelled as
though he was solely responsible for the
town's aesthetic qualities the people
are wonderful too is she'll discover
come inside I'm sure you're both hungry
and tired Hannah has made coffee and
spiced cake I'll help you with these
Alan lovely to see you my boy
Horace picked up Emma's trunk and
continued chatting to Alan as the two
men mounted the porch steps Emma
followed a few paces behind the
second and empty windows of the town
seeming to gaze at her from every
direction as if they had seen into her
very soul and found it wanting the
inside of the house was dim led only by
two gas lamps when the group entered a
young woman looked up from her sewing
Emma knew this must be Hannah Allen's
twin sister but she was immediately
struck by how little they resembled one
another whereas Allen was well built
with angular features and intense dark
eyes Hannah was a wand fragile creature
with dull blond hair pulled severely
back from a homely asymmetrical face her
eyes were watery blue and ringed with
red Hannah did not rise from her chair
and did not smile as Emma approached she
simply offered a limp and in greeting
Emma took it only to find the fingers
hard and cold like iron rods beneath a
thin veneer of flesh in The Gaslight the
girl's pale eyes seemed to contain
something fierce
nice to meet you Hannah Allen has told
me so much about you in fact Allen had
only mentioned her once or twice and
then vaguely like something nearly
forgotten but Emma thought the girl
might like the thought of her brother
speaking lovingly of her Hannah appeared
to crave no such comfort she nodded and
acknowledgment of Emma's statements and
very deliberately lowered her head and
went back to her sewing Emma opened her
mouth perhaps to chastise the girl but
at that moment mr. Bell came up behind
her and touched her arm gently guiding
her safar into the room where Allen was
fussing with the trunks don't judge her
too harshly miss mr. bell whispered
inclining his head in the direction of
his daughter she's never been right if
you catch my meaning besides she's been
keeping late nights these past weeks
working on the children's costumes for
the festival is that what she's sewing
Emma glanced back at the shimmering
white fabric in Hannah's lap with
renewed interest horace chuckled they
get to be ghosts and goblins once a year
and they insist on new and better
costumes for every festival poor Hannah
works her fingers to the bone but it's
all worth it when you see the finished
products he encircled both Emma and
Allen with his powerful arms now I'll
take you to the shop and show you what
I've been working on
he led them out through a door in the
kitchen night had fallen and except for
the hard shining stars spangling the sky
the town was in darkness mr. bell seemed
to have no trouble navigating his boots
crunched on the path leading to the long
looming structure behind the house Emma
pulled her shawl closer across her
shoulders the workshop was cavernous
even after mr. bell lit the lamps inky
puddles of shadow pooled in every corner
and the ceiling was completely invisible
but in the feeble glow it was readily
apparent the space held a profusion of
wonders Emma gasped as she took in the
scene everywhere was the gleam of
exquisitely carved wood a riot of shapes
and movement cherubs and stately angels
spiraling columns hooked by life like
vines of Ivy foxes and rabbits and
staring owls the clock faces were works
of art in their own right smooth
mother-of-pearl glimmering with soft
rainbow tones bisected by iron hands all
of which stood dead still at 12:00 why
are they stopped
Emma was not willing to admit that the
sight of so many silenced clocks made a
chill scurry up her spine I don't whine
them until they found a home mr. bell
said his eyes twinkling here's my latest
masterpiece Emma approached it Allan
close behind it was only about two feet
tall but made up for its small size in
its intricacy of detail the oval face
painted with tiny swirling leaves was
surrounded by a carved cascade of
beautifully rendered apples wheat stalks
grapes and gourds the fruits gleamed
with an almost supernatural fire and
Emma felt a sudden desire to reach out
and pluck one of the apples from the
carving fully expecting it to turn lush
and crimson in her hand
its she struggled for a word though
everyone fell short of the mark mr. bell
seemed to understand
thank you my dear he said it's the
culmination of the work I've done here
my tribute to bounty Falls astonishing
said Emma finally still finding the word
inadequate but glad to say something
indeed father you've outdone yourself
Alan took a step forward his rugged
features strangely shadowed in the gas
light Emma and I passed the new factory
on our way into town he said peering
around the workshop Emma feels that
progress is coming for us all Emma was
about to protest but when she saw the
transformation in Horace Belle's face
she decided to keep silent
the old man's mouth pressed flat and a
vein throbbed in his high forehead
progress he said clocks and costumes
machines making the two things that have
always kept Hananiah float and making
every clock every garment just like
every other one soon everyone in town
will have the same clock on his
mantelpiece as everyone else has and all
the children will go to the festival
with not even their parents being able
to tell them apart I ask you missus that
progress Emma felt her cheeks growing
hot
mr. Bella I surely didn't mean that the
factory was a positive development
merely that it might be inevitable mr.
bell glared at her so fiercely that for
a moment Emma feared her heart might
freeze in her chest then the old man's
expression softened inevitable he
repeated his voice weary on that you may
be correct miss the individual who owns
the factory is a scoundrel of my long
acquaintance and I know for certain it
was built there specifically to destroy
me but perhaps as you say the days of
craftsmanship are over that would be a
great shame Emma said partly to placate
him but partly because she meant it
later that evening
Emma lay beneath the quilts in a narrow
bed in an upstairs room since meeting
Alan she had usually spent her nights
imagining what it would be like when
they were married when Alan would lie
next to her his warm breath tickling the
back of her neck it had always been a
pleasant fantasy to fall asleep too but
tonight she was far too distracted her
brain was a hive of questions and
disturbing images of fire and dancing
phantoms and shining clock faces she
thought these notions would keep her
awake for hours to come but before she
was aware of it exhaustion took over and
she slept
moonlight was streaming into the room
when she woke again bolting upright
clutching one of the quilts to her
breasts that sound for a moment her
racing mind couldn't place it but then
her knuckles tightened so hard on the
fabric that the bone seemed poised to
poke through the skin clocks a monstrous
symphony of ticking clocks each keeping
to its own pace in apparent indifference
to the pace of the others so the ticking
was overlapping disjointed and horrible
Emma looked wildly around the room
though she had no lamp the pale white
moon cast enough illumination to show
that the small room lacked a single
clock even if there had been could a
single clock makes such a cacophony like
the clacking of a Thousand Devils hooves
Emma crawled from the bed pulling the
quilt up around her ears to muffle the
sound that seemed to be behind the walls
and everywhere she pushed aside the
curtains and peered out the window the
workshop hunched there in the moonlight
still in silent Emma had a vision of the
clocks coming to life at once through
some demonic agency ticking away the
moments until doomsday she tried to
chide herself for her folly but found
she could not for surely midnight had
passed and wasn't it now the eve of All
Saints Day when the veil between the
living and the dead was at its most
porous Emma had never placed much stock
in superstitions but now with the clocks
hellish voices assaulting her from all
directions she found herself clapping
her hands together in murmuring fervent
prayers like a frightened child the
sound seemed to grow louder and Emma
tore from the window and dived for the
bed burying herself under the quilts
clamping her hands over her ears curling
herself into a tight ball and squeezing
her eyes closed in this way she lay
battered by the clamor waiting and
wishing for the swift onset of dawn
another sound a soft rapping woke her
again though now the room was bright
with autumn sunshine and the alluring
smells of coffee and griddle cakes
permeated the air the knocking was
repeated and Emma sat up are you up yet
darling said Allen I'm going down to
breakfast
Emma confused by her surroundings unsure
of the reality of the events in the
night managed to stammer go on ahead
I'll be a few minutes she heard his
heavy tread descending the stairs had it
all been a vivid dream she tilted her
head listening and thought she could
hear very faintly a furtive ripple of
ticking sounds she strained to hear more
but the sound eluded her crossly she
threw aside the quilts only to notice
that the pattern decorating the fabric
were a disturbing resemblance to the
interlocking gears of clockworks Emma's
skin went cold and she leapt from the
bed pushing the covers violently away as
though they were diseased as she stood
there rubbing her arms to rid them of
the quilts tainted warmth she knew she
was being ridiculous Hannah had likely
made the quilts after all and as her
father was a clock maker why wouldn't
she use a clock motif in her handiwork
this explanation was perfectly
reasonable but Emma could not shake the
visceral aversion she felt when she
looked at the patterns nerves thrumming
she quickly dressed and made her way
downstairs for breakfast the Sun was
bright when Emma left the house
breakfast had been an uncomfortable
affair with slope faced Hannah appearing
suspiciously at her across the table and
Allen barely saying a word and fidgeting
in his seat periodically glancing out
the windows with a crinkled brow only
Horace seemed cheerful eating his
griddle cakes with great relish talking
endlessly about his clocks and the
festival taking place that evening emma
was only half listening she thought she
could still hear a distant ticking
outside now with Allen silently smoking
a cigar in the straight back chair next
to her Emma watched the townsfolk
preparing for the festivities
it seemed surreal to see such a bustle
after the desolation of the day before
and for a moment Emma got the feeling
that people were not real at all but
simply painted cutouts being manipulated
by some unseen force strictly for her
benefit
Emma shook herself she usually took
pride in the fact that she was a
sensible woman and not prone to flights
of fancy
but ever since arriving in bounty Falls
she'd been entertaining ideas that
distressed her by their proximity to
lunacy even now she was still hearing
maddening hints of clocks ticking coming
from seemingly everywhere at once her
head began to pound Horus had retreated
to his workshop to finish his latest
clock that he planned to present to the
town at the culmination of the festival
Hanna had vanished among the crowds
bearing armloads of multicolored fabrics
the last of the costume she had made for
the children everyone else in town
seemed to be occupied in some way
arranging bundles of sticks in the
square for the bonfire hanging bunting
scrubbing windows and porch steps the
smell of roasting meat and baking pies
saturated the crisp autumn air Emma
experienced these things distantly as
though she was reading about them rather
than seeing them occurring in front of
her she had the persistent feeling that
gaiety and Industry on display was a
veneer a thin covering over something
much darker seething beneath to Emma the
odour of collective anxiety emanating
from the busy townsfolk overrode the
aromas of the feast being prepared
suddenly cold Emma snatched her gaze
away from the scene
Allen she noticed was pointedly avoiding
looking at it also cigar and mouth he
was staring fixedly down at his hands as
though he had never seen them before
thinking at an unwise question but
nevertheless curious Emma asked why
aren't you helping them she expected him
to snap at her but for a long moment he
acted as though he hadn't heard emma was
going to say something else but then
Allen turned his head and looked at her
his eyes were hollow and frightened I
don't want any part of it he said and
briefly it seemed to Emma that the faint
ticking she'd been hearing grew
perceptibly louder
it seemed he wanted to say more but then
his expression caved in further as if he
was struggling to remember something
Emma glanced out toward the town square
again and swore she saw Hannah still
holding the now diminished pile of
fabrics staring hard at her from several
hundred yards away she tried to shake
off the assertion what happens at the
festival
she asked feeling the need to whisper
even though the townspeople were too far
away to hear
Allen looked away nothing really a feast
a bonfire the children dance in their
costumes that's all
the Sun went behind a cloud and the
temperature seemed to drop several
degrees emma pulled her shawl across her
shoulders why don't you want any part of
it Allen she genuinely wanted to know
but when he opened his mouth to answer
she found herself wishing he would say
nothing were announced they were leaving
bounty Falls immediately I forgotten he
said scrubbing at his face with his
hands he looked pale and Haggard
I always forget with this mystifying
reply Allen seemed to have said
everything he wished to say on the
subject he turned away from her lit
another cigar and went back to
scrutinizing his hands
Emma seeing that the now empty handed
Hannah was heading purposefully back
toward the house excused herself and
hurried back inside her headache was
worsening and her disturbed sleep of the
night before was now catching up to her
she climbed the stairs to a room and
locked the door behind her Emma had not
intended to sleep the entire day away
but when she woke the light outside her
window was low and orange casting long
shadows across the timepiece quilts that
covered her she could hear children
laughing somewhere below and the smells
of food cooking and wood burning
assaulted her nostrils her headache had
subsided to a dull thud but the phantom
ticking seemed more prominent Emma sat
up feeling sluggish and out of sorts
rising from the bed she smoothed her
dress and hair and made her way down
stairs Allen was nowhere to be seen but
Horace was in the kitchen
transferring pies from cooling racks to
trays while Hannah knelt by the fire
making adjustments to a hooded cape worn
by an angel faced blond child be still
Myles she said and Emma was shocked into
stillness by the sound of Hannah's voice
which had a deep droning resonance like
the peal of a gong it wasn't at all what
Emma imagined a girl like Hannah would
sound like the child in the robe whose
face was painted green to match the
fabric beamed at Hannah my model was
going to get our costumes from that
factory store this year Myles said but I
told her I wouldn't have one unless Miss
Hannah made it my brother said as much
to Horace turned from his task his oaken
face a wreath of smiles that's a good
boy Myles
I'll save you an extra piece of Miss
Hannah
how's that mile smacked his lips in a
charmingly unselfconscious fashion and
emma fancied she almost saw Hannah's
mouth curling upwards though it may have
just been a trick of the light up until
now no one had seemed to notice Emma's
presence on the stairs
but then Horace glanced up his eyes
sparkling with the knowledge that she'd
been there all along I hope you had a
nice rest miss he said I know how
exhausting all this can be if you're
looking for Alan I think he's in the
workshop it occurred to Emma that she
might have offered to help the bells
with their festival preparations but
Horace his last pronouncement had the
distinct flavor of a dismissal so Emma
nodded to him and Hannah in turn then
went through the back door out into the
dusk light from the high windows of the
workshop sliced down into the vast space
catching the curves of wooden angel's
wings and rabbit haunches when Emma
entered she couldn't see Alan at all but
after a moment her eyes adjusted and she
could just make out his rigid silhouette
his broad back facing her he looked like
one of his father's carvings well-formed
and motionless
Emma was transfixed by the sight of him
my father wanted me to go into the trade
you know Alan said suddenly startling
Emma as much as if one of the clocks had
spoken he turned his head so that the
shafts of the Setting Sun fell upon his
chiseled profile I always hated them
though the clocks before I left bound a
Falls I used to stand in here and wonder
what it would be like to turn over a
lamp and watch them burn to ashes Alan
she sputtered wanting to move closer to
him to reassure herself of his reality
but not daring how can you say such a
thing your father's work is so beautiful
Alan turned fully toward her then a thin
smile ratcheting across the lower half
of his face yes he said it is beautiful
isn't it
he began moving toward her as though he
was in a trance a marionette pulled by
strings Emma's first instinct was to
turn and run but surely she was being
ridiculous again this was Alan Bell who
she'd known for two years who would soon
be her wedded husband she would not run
from him no matter how peculiar he
seemed Alan she began
just then there was a shout from outside
and a ragged cheer followed by scattered
laughter something flickered across
Alan's shadowed face then it passed and
he seemed quite himself again
his gaze focused past Emma as if he
could see through the workshop wall to
the town square beyond the festival is
starting he said Emma walked into the
square with her hand gripping Allen's
arm the population of bounty Falls had
seemingly multiplied for every porch and
patch of grass and dusty roadway seized
with people the Sun had just slipped
below the horizon and tortures had been
lit around the perimeter of the square
sending waves of heat and warped yellow
light into the encroaching darkness long
tables laden with food formed a you
around the man hi bundle of sticks that
would serve as the bonfire most of the
town's folk had already begun
celebrating piling their plates with
meat and steaming mounds of vegetables
drinking heavily from tankards of ale
costume children flitted through the
crowds trailing silk and ribbon like the
fingers of phantoms their faces tiny
replicas of skulls demons and goblins
everywhere was the sound of laughing and
raucous conversation broken up by the
occasional mock shriek is one of the
children sprang from beneath the table
the scene was utterly delightful the
aromas enticing the sounds of gaiety
inviting yet Emma's hold on Allen's arm
tightened further as they approached
even though she had eaten nothing since
breakfast Emma found she had no appetite
and refused Allen's offer of a plate
Allen for his part appeared just as
reluctant to partake and only nibbled at
a piece of bread he plucked from one of
the tables he was still acting oddly his
face set like marble but now it seemed
he had resigned himself to whatever was
going to occur
Emma's gaze darted through the crowd
settling on laughing faces on the
grotesque countenances of the disguised
children she thought that in the end
there was no difference that the
children were simply manifesting the
aspects of the adults that were usually
kept well-hidden she shuddered and
turned her head away from the spectacle
but there her eyes met those of Hannah
who was standing alone beneath the porch
awning arms folded across her chest
Emma quickly looked away and pressed
farther into the crowd to escape the
unsettling scrutiny
when she found herself at the edge of
the bonfire sight a hush fell over the
crowd and for a moment all Emma could
hear was the sharp crackle of the
torches and that insistent elusive
ticking that had been dancing around the
boundaries of her consciousness all day
then the door to horace bell shop opened
and the man himself emerged clad in a
smart black suit and bearing his
marvellous harvest clock its polished
wood seeming to glow in the firelight
the townspeople gasped at the sight of
it and at an unseen signal two men
separated themselves from the assemblage
and retrieved a large wooden pedestal
that they had placed in the center of
the gap made by the arrayed tables
horace placed the clock reverently on
the pedestal and then raised his eyes to
the crowd this clock is dedicated to the
essence of bounty Falls he said a God's
Proclamation spiraling into the night I
present it tonight at harvests end on
the night when time becomes mutable when
all falsehood is stripped away to reveal
the truth at the very core of ourselves
may it bring you continued comfort and
prosperity as long as bounty Falls
endures he gave a small bow and then
amid the suspended silence he produced a
tiny silver key from the pocket of his
coat and proceeded to wind the beautiful
clock the ticking when it began seemed
as loud as the heavens light the bonfire
Horus bell shouted Emma watched as
though in a dream the ticking
penetrating to her very bones the men in
the crowd cleared away the banquet
tables leaving the enormous pile of
sticks alone in the center of the square
for children resplendent in ghoulish
finery came forward small torches
clutched in their hands they
simultaneously thrust their torches into
the pile and then backed away to watch
as the flames caught and spread ejecting
sparks that flew like meteors across the
purple sky the bonfire was still low
waiting for that critical moment when it
would burst upward from its prison of
sticks tasting the air with its feelers
of flame but even in its modest glow
Emma began to see a change overtaking
the townspeople she still felt detached
and unreal and so it was not
particularly alarmed when she saw that
the children nearest the fire no longer
appeared to be children neither did they
appear to be the goblins they
masqueraded as to emma their outer
shells seemed to be dissipating
revealing what lay beneath the gleaming
Springs and interlocking gears of
elaborate clock works ticking in a
maddening inevitable way just below the
veneer of flesh and bone Emma's gaze
swept the crowd and yes she thought she
could see everyone's true selves now as
the bonfire gains strength and
brightness motors and Springs and gears
marking the minutes inside each body
counting the time controlling the motion
Emma's vision swam and she could feel
the heat of the rising fire tightening
the skin of her face they're nothing but
puppets ten soldiers she thought and
almost laughed and then she glanced at
Allen and she did laugh because behind
his handsome and familiar face
he was ticking - moving and thinking in
time with the clicking gears perhaps I'm
nothing but clockwork myself Emma
thought and considered looking down at
her hands to check but couldn't quite
bring herself to do it instead she fixed
her attention on the wonderful clock apt
symbol of bounty Falls the light from
the flames blazed around it tracing a
bright Corona around the carved bounty
on its living surface behind its
mother-of-pearl face Emma found herself
peering into the vastness of space moons
and stars and planets ticking along
their crystalline orbits marking the
passing of infinity she could have
easily become lost in the steady
enormity of the clockwork universe but
she was torn from her trance by the
sudden frenzy of the crowd bodies
jostling against her and the sound of
rapidly approaching carriage wheels she
struggled to see through the mob the
carriage was tall and black under the
moonlight pulled by two massive white
horses it clattered to a halt at the
edge of the square and then the driver
lept down and pulled open the door
Emma fought her way to a small gap in
the crowd she wasn't sure who she was
expecting to emerge from the carriage
but the person who did absolutely
stunned her it was a woman very tall and
well muscled she was dressed in a
peculiar garment that reminded Emma of
the robes worn by ancient Romans draped
in marble white accented with gold
threads the woman's hair was coppery red
and fell loose around her proud face the
crowd still tensely murmuring backed
away in one body as the extraordinary
woman stepped forward into the firelight
like the others the bonfire seemed to
have an effect on her peeling away the
outer layers of her being but beneath
her transparent shell there lay no
clockwork there was only a sense of
unbelievable antiquity of mountains
rising and crumbling seas filling and
receding rocks forming in the crust of
the earth the fire suited her features
bringing her nature to the surface
before she could speak Horace Bell
appeared at the front of the crowd
Emma realized she had yet to see him in
the transforming glow of the bonfire
when she did she was little surprised to
see no clockwork behind his skin for he
was the clock maker was he not his
essence
Emma could see now was one of unchanging
time a universe fixed upon its regular
cycles just as she had seen behind the
face of the harvest clock that he had
made Emma's gaze found Allen standing
not far from the edge of the bonfire she
made her way back to him still feeling
dreamlike but grasping for something
familiar who is that woman
Allen looked at her as if he had never
seen her before the gears clicking
behind his eyes the factory his voice
was a monotone Emma was going to ask
what he meant but then Horace's shrill
voice pierced the air get away he was
standing so close to the woman that his
breath fluttered her hair I don't want
you here the woman smiled and behind her
eyes comets fell and seeded the oceans
with organisms that began splitting
multiplying you can't keep me out
forever old man she said and then her
gaze fixed quite suddenly on Emma
picking her out from the crowd with
eerie precision progress will win out in
the end will it not my dear
Emma's blood froze in her veins and time
itself seemed to pause then in slow
motion
dozens of clockwork faces turned toward
her the firelight casting devilish
shadows she shrank from them knowing
they perceived her as a collude ur a
henchman of progress when all they
wanted was stability order and sameness
she tried to protest but the fervid
ticking of the town's infernal mechanics
swallowed her voice even Allen seemed to
have turned on her Allen who had
forgotten why he left this town
forgotten what it was like to see what
he really was when she looked into his
eyes pleading silently for help she saw
nothing there but programmed rage empty
of reason they pushed her until she
could see only their transparent faces
blotting out the blackening sky the fire
was hot at her back and she turned this
way and that fighting them with her
hands they pressed in and she saw that
the hem of her dress had caught the
flames dancing merrily around her feet
and then she screamed but heard no sound
desperately she swung and clawed at the
faces nearest her by virtue of sheer
hysteria she broke and ran tearing
through the crowd like a flaming arrow
running as fast as her burning legs
would carry her running to no particular
end but just to get away to escape from
the clutching talons of the clockwork
City she thought she saw Hannah before
her as she ran and in Hannah's heart
face she saw plainly the story of bounty
Falls a spooling vision of a god-like
old man and an experiment for a perfect
unchanging world Emma had only a second
to feel sorry for Hannah for dear Allen
for all of them living their regulated
lives at the whim of their maker then
the black shape of the workshop loomed
and she forced Hannah aside and foul
plunging forward her legs finally giving
out in the moments before the flames
consumed her Emma saw her own hand in
the truth bearing light and it comforted
her to see the tiny atoms splitting
changing moving in unexpected ways I am
NOT like them she thought and she raised
her eyes to take in the stately dying
universe shining behind every clock face
in mr. Bell's workshop then she lay back
upon the shops floorboards as the
unpredictable flame swallowed her up and
reached out for more
[Laughter]
death were the seeming of a battered
Chevrolet the child's scream and the
screech of rubber on concrete knife
through two seconds of time before
snapping like a celery stalk of sound
into aching silence the silence of limbo
called into being for the space of a
slow heartbeat then the thud of running
feet
the rising hubbub of many voices give
her air keep back don't try to move her
somebody call an ambulance yeah and
somebody call a cop too I couldn't help
it it was the driver of the ramshackle
Chevy she fell off the curb right in
front of me honest to god it wasn't my
fault
got a report these things right away
said the gray-haired man beside him no
cause to worry if you ain't to blame
probably no brakes said a heavily
accented voice and another spoke as if
on cue probably no insurance either let
me through oh please the woman's voice
was on the edge of hysteria she came
through the crowd like an automaton not
seeing the people she shoved in elbowed
aside
do a said the woman heavily her face was
no longer twisted with shock and she was
almost pretty again DOA dead on arrival
it means Oh Jim I never knew they said
that suddenly there were tears in her
blue eyes there had been many tears now
take it easy Jean honey
Jim Blair hoisted his leg six feet out
of the old rocker and crossed the room
running a nervous hand through his
corn-shuck hair she's only 30 he thought
and I'm three years older that's awfully
young to a bread three kids and lost
them he took her in his arms I know how
tough it is it's bad enough for me and
probably worse for you but at least
we're sure they'll never be bomb fodder
and we still have Joanna she twisted
away from him her voice suddenly bitter
don't give me that Pollyanna stuff Jim
goody-goody only a broken leg it might
have been your back there's no use
trying to whitewash it our kids our own
kids all gone dead she began to sob I
wish I were to Jean I don't care I mean
it everything bad has happened since
Joanna came to live with us darling you
can't blame the child for a series of
accidents I know
she raised her tear-stained face but
after all
Michael drowned then Steve falling off
the water tower now it's Marian her
fingers gripped his arm tightly Jim each
of them was playing alone with Joanna
when it happened
accidents just accidents he said it
wasn't like Jean this talk almost his
mind shied away from the word and
circled back almost paranoid the Jean
was stable rational always had been
still maybe a little chat with dr.
Holland would be a good idea breakdowns
did happen they both turned at the
slamming of the screen door then came
the patter of childish feet on the
kitchen linoleum and Joanna burst into
the room mommy I want to play with
Marian why can't I play with Marian
gene put her arm around the girls thin
shoulder darling you won't be able to
play with Marion for quite a while you
mustn't worry about it now mommy she
looked like she was just asleep then
they came and took her away her lips
trembled I'm frightened mommy Jim looked
down at the dark eyes missed it now the
straight brown hair and the little snub
nose with his dusting of freckles she's
all we have left poor kid and not even
ours really Helen's baby he looked up as
the battered cuckoo clock on the mantel
clicked warningly time for little girls
to be in bed Joanna
run along now like a good girl and get
washed even as he spoke the miniature
doors flew open and the caricature of a
bird popped out shrilly announcing the
hour it cuckoo date times then bounced
back inside
Joanna watched entranced bedtime darling
said Jeanne gently school tomorrow
remember and don't forget to brush your
teeth
I won't good night mommy good night
daddy she turned up her face to be
kissed smiled at them and was gone they
listened to her footsteps on the stairs
Jim I'm sorry about the things I said
Gene's voice was hesitant a little
ashamed
it is hard though you know it is Jim
aren't you listening after all you don't
have to watch the clock now her smile
was his labored as the joke he smiled
back I think I'll take a walk honey some
fresh air would do me good Jim don't go
I'd rather not be alone just now well he
looked at her keeping his expression
blank alright dear how about some coffee
I could stand another cup and he thought
tomorrow I'll go I'll talk to Holland
tomorrow
let me get this straight Jim Holland's
pudgy face was sober his eyes serious
you started out by thinking gene was
showing paranoid tendencies an offhand
I'm inclined to agree with you overnight
you changed your mind it began thinking
that maybe just maybe she might be right
honestly don't you suspect your own
reasons for such a quick switch sure I
do Bob Blair said worriedly do you think
I haven't beaten out my brains over it I
know the idea is monstrous but just
suppose there was a branch of humanity
if you could call it human living off us
unsuspected a branch that knows how to
eliminate competition almost by instinct
now hold on a minute Jim you've taken
genes reaction to this last death plus a
random association with a cuckoo clock
and here you are with the perfectly wild
hypothesis
you've always been rational and
analytical old man surely you can
realize that a perfectly normal urge to
rationalize genes conclusions is making
you concur with them against your better
judgment Bob I'm not through Jim just
consider how fantastic the whole idea is
because of a series of accidents you
can't accuse a child a planned murder
nor can you further hypothesize that all
orphans are changelings imbued with an
instinct to polish off their foster
siblings not all orphans Bob not planned
murder either take it easy
just some of them a few of them
different growing up placing their young
with well-to-do families somehow and
then dropping unobtrusively out of the
picture and the young growing up and
always the natural children dying off in
one way or another the changeling
inherits in the process is repeated step
by step can you say it's impossible do
you know it's impossible
I wouldn't say impossible Jim but I
would say that your thesis has a
remarkably low index of probability why
don't other suspect besides you Jim
spread his hands hopelessly I don't know
maybe they do maybe these creatures if
they do exist have some means of
protection we don't know about you need
more than maybes Jim what about Joanna
Simmons mother according to your theory
she should have been well off was she no
she wasn't
Jim admitted reluctantly she came here
and took a job with my outfit said she
was divorced and had lived in New York
then she quit to take a position in
California and
agreed to board Joann until she got
settled Warren burg was to town she was
killed there quite horribly at a
terrible auto accident have you any
reason for suspecting skullduggery
honestly Jim or for labeling her one of
your human cuckoos only my hunch we had
a newspaper clipping and a letter from
the coroner we even sent the money for
her funeral but those things could be
faked Bob give me some evidence that
they were faked and I'll be happy to
rien SPECT your views pollen got up out
of his chair
in the meantime relax take a trip if he
can try not to worry Jim grinned
humorlessly mustn't let myself get
excited eh okay Bob but if I get hold of
any evidence that I think you might
accept I'll be back last laugh and all
that pending developments you take it
easy - don't let yourself get overworked
stay out of the Sun so long now so long
Jim it was cool in the Warren burg City
Hall though outside the streets were
sizzling sorry mr. Blair said the stout
motherly woman with the horn-rimmed
glasses we've no record of a Helen
Simmons nothing whatever she closed the
file with resolute finality Jim stared
at her are you sure there must be
something might there be a special file
for accident cases she was here in
Warren burg he died here
the woman thinned her lips and shook her
head if we had any information it'd be
right where I looked there isn't a thing
have you tried her last address maybe
they could tell you something we can't
I'll try that next thanks a lot
sorry we couldn't help you he went out
slowly
872 maple was a rambling frame house
dozing on a wide flower bordered lot
there was nothing sleepy about the
diminutive woman who opened the door to
Jim's knock snapping black eyes peered
at him from a maze of wrinkles a vain
hand moved swiftly to smooth down the
white hair that framed her face looking
for someone young man just information
mrs. Collins and it's miss don't give
out information about guests you a bill
collector no miss Collins as a matter of
fact I'm trying to check up on an old
friend I lost track of Helen Simmons she
lived at this address for a while sure
did we'll come on in mind you I don't
usually do this Mr Blair
without any fanfare a bill changed hands
Mr Blair well I can't tell you much try
that green chair for size what do you
want to know Jim studied the toe of his
right shoe
his eyes were veiled I heard she was
hurt and hard up and I was worried my
wife and I were friends of hers back
east hurt hard up
not likely spending all her time driving
that English car around taking trips I'm
not saying she didn't mind her manners
though did she have any close friends
she was chummy with Edith Walton that
girl that works for Doc Mendel
he's County coroner in a spare time no
men didn't fool around at all
I'd have known behind jim stony eyes the
pattern took clearer form as if a mosaic
approached completion a mosaic of
carefully planned events that totaled
horror he shivered as the outlines of
his hunch filled in Helen what creatures
were these Helen not dead not pour
carefully planting ostensible proof of
her death and going on to a new role a
new life in London or Paris or Rome a
free untrammeled life and her child if
child was the word in his home repeating
the pattern eliminating competition as
her mother undoubtedly had done the
competition his and jeans children
changeling no not that Incubus he
shivered again rabbits on Your Grave mr.
Blair he looked up slowly sorry I was
just wondering did miss Simmons have a
job while she was here no she didn't
one thing she did do was rent a place
used to be Bland's hardware paid a
month's rent to
said some friends of hers were planted
open a mortuary seemed like a funny way
for people to do business but then no
affair of mine funny no not funny at all
but eiseley eerily logical there had to
be an undertaking parlor where he could
send the funeral expenses he wondered if
helen had laughed when she opened the
letter everyone his or her own
Undertaker and the carefully cultivated
friend in the coroner's office for
stationery he got to his feet thanks a
lot miss Collins you've been a great
deal of help he almost smiled as he
asked I don't suppose she left a
forwarding address the old head shook
decisively not a thing just packed and
left one Monday morning all the loose
ends tied up tight on a Monday morning
nothing to cause suspicion nothing to
worry about only a woman's almost
paranoid hysteria and a glance at a
clock not very much to unmask Incubus
and what could he do what could he do
start talking and land in an institution
well there was one thing thanks again
miss Collins
he went out swanson didn't look like the
general conception of a small-town
newspaper man when knew instinctively
that his beard wouldn't have been
tobacco stained even if he'd cared to
grow one and he didn't have a bottle of
bourbon in the file marked miscellaneous
or if he did he didn't bring it out that
never came from my paper
he said precisely he handed the clipping
back to Jim we don't use that type for
one thing for another miss Simmons so
far as I know wasn't killed here or
anywhere else
you knew her I knew of her I never met
her what about this report of her death
Swanson shrugged tented manicured
fingers it's a hoax any job printing
shop with a Linotype could do it in all
likelihood it was someplace in San
Francisco that's closest it would be
very difficult to check his curiosity
was showing
I see well thanks for your time in
trouble mr. Swanson not at all
sorry I couldn't be a more help one
thing to do one thing that must be done
Motors over the mountains and riding
with them the numb resolve Motors over
the salt pans the wheat lands the Corn
Belt the stewardess stops again Coffee
sir a sandwich perhaps I beg your own oh
no thanks she watches him covertly
uneasily longing for the end of the run
motors in the night and the dull
determination growing strengthening the
airport baggage the ancient taxi with
the piston slap and it lasts the dark
familiar Street Jim you're back
Oh Jim darling next time they send you
West I'm going to I am ok jeans sure why
not what's the matter dear oh you're
tired of course I should have known sit
down Jim let me get you a drink in a
minute Jeanne do it now now now where's
Joanna she's in bed hours ago
Jim has something nothing dear I just
want to look in on her and freshen up a
bit of course Jim he smoothed away the
worried frown with his forefinger in a
minute dear she smiled uncertainly hurry
back Jim the stairs unwind irrevocably
slow motion and a nightmare the bedroom
door opens the hall light dim on the bed
and the child's face Incubus and the
half dark for a moment Jim remembered
wandering somewhere sometime what
strange powers of protection might be
implicit in such a creature as the
thought came into his mind Joanna
stirred she opened her eyes and looked
at him he took one step toward the bed
the little girl eyes over there dusting
of freckles slitted then they opened
wide became two glowing golden lakes
that grew and grew there was the feeling
of a great soundless explosion in his
mind waves of cool burning in his brain
churning and bubbling in every unknown
corner every cranny here and there a
cell or a group of cells blanked out the
complex molecules reverting becoming new
again ready for fresh punch marks
synapses shorted with soundless cold
fire and waited in timeless stasis for
reach and Ling the waves frost became
ripples were gone
he stood unmoving what was it he was
supposed to do let's see
tuck Joanna's blanket around her but she
was covered up snugly sleeping soundly -
and for a few seconds he thought she was
awake and Jean was waiting downstairs
Jean and a cool drink oh yes stop in the
bathroom the stairs wind up again it's
good to be with one's family relaxed in
the well-known chair not a worry in the
world he sat there his mind at ease not
caring much about anything he didn't
even look up when the clock on the
mantel word and the ridiculous bird
popped out of its nest to herald a new
day